just want to bring you some breaking
news we're getting this from
lancashire's police and crime
commissioner Andrew Snowden it's in
relation to the Nicola bully case uh
Lancashire police the police and crime
Commissioners saying that he has
commissioned the College of policing to
carry out a full independent review
alongside the independent scrutiny that
will come from the information
commissioner's office and the
independent office for police conduct
and the corridors process in to the
Nicola bully case
um the commissioner says although the
hypothesis of the police investigation
on how Nicola went missing was sadly
proven to be correct and significant
resources were dedicated to the search
the case has prompted unprecedented
public and media interest and certain
elements of how the case and information
relating to the investigation were
handled have been a cause for public
concern this review will have three
clear areas of focus investigation and
search communication and public
engagement and the releasing of personal
information so that is lancashire's
police and crime commissioner announcing
that there will be a full independent
review Into the investigation Into The
Disappearance of Nicola bully it comes
after Lancashire police also announced a
little earlier that the police Watchdog
will be carrying out a review of a
um
visit that was made to Nicola bully a
welfare visit that was made Nicola bully
in the days before she went missing so
some significant announcements from
Lancashire police this afternoon